je vais faire un peu de ménage on fera
ce sera plutôt demain les visites
commencent demain 9h n'oublie pas ça va
intéresser des jeunes acheteurs à cause
des étages on pourrait sûrement obtenir
un million de lampes desquels je veux
pas que les lits agissent comme si
c'était notre mais j'ai vu tout demain
comme convenu à 8h30 nous adorons ton
travail actuellement le marché est
plutôt tournée vers de jeunes artistes
il veut que nous partions écoutez là
c'est vous qui avez le marché en main
d'accord des couples vont pratiquement
offert leur premier enfant
tout ça c'est trop relax ça c'est mon
travail j'ai vu plein de choses sur ces
portes ouvertes les gens voltz je vis
cloud et toutes nos affaires au sol ils
ont arrêté le chauffeur succès voir si
on peut faire tomber ce mur s'agrandir
et la chance ici un bel espace une fois
débarrassé doivent allonger pour voir si
je dormirai bien dans cette chambre
vous pouvez éteindre cette ligne c'est
quoi une chambre d'ado les sur quoi et
des lits superposés
ah bah si c'est le cas on subit lors je
trouve ça très joli
mairiga
nous n'avons pas encore dans le témoin
nous sommes installés à brooklyn
nous avions cet endroit ça tombait bien
c'est génial
regarde c'est parti oui parce qu'on veut
rouvrir le marché
on ne veut plus de votre appartement et
j'espère que vous en tirez au moins un
million
on a toujours fait ce qu'on voulait on
s'est mariés quand c'était encore
illégal dans une trentaine d'états leur
dis moi c'est quoi trouver un
appartement comparé à tout ce qu'on a
vécu
puis ce qu'on recherche on ne s'est pas
construit une belle vie vous perdez
c'est ta part quelle importance
j'en ai beaucoup d'autres
nous pouvons faire exactement ce que
nous venons top la route